so with the death of Wolverine part 4
comes the conclusion of the death of
Wolverine event and what we see here is
that we're picking up with Wolverine and
Paradise Valley Nevada now if you recall
our discussion about the death of
Wolverine part 3 we had talked about how
when Wolverine was conversing with ogen
an Odin had told Wolverine this is where
dr. Abraham Cornelius was headquartered
at that he was at Paradise Valley in
Nevada and so what Wolverine is doing
here is effectively breaking in for the
purpose of doing whatever it is that it
is that he's looking to do perhaps most
likely defeat or even kill dr. Cornelius
and so what happens is Wolverine
actually enters the facility is that he
realizes that dr. Cornelius appears to
be trying to re-implement the adamantium
project that is to say to plant
adamantium inside the bodies of other
people now he asked dr. Cornelius why it
is that he's doing this why it is this
is happening then dr. Cornelius says
that he does not want his legacy to be
Wolverine he wants to be known for
something more than creating a killer in
addition he says that these people are
going to be conditioned if they're going
to be I guess programmed in such a way
to where they will have the same
capacities as will bring the healing
factor of Wolverine the adamantium
skeleton and the the fighting I guess
the prodigious nature of Wolverines
fighting skills but more so than that
they will carry out the instructions of
people who give them to them they will
not rebill in the same way Wolverine had
done and so what dr. Cornelius continues
to say here is that the issue or I guess
the idea of bringing Wolverine here was
not to gain Wolverines adamantium eddie
has a multitude of I guess of sources of
adamantium but even more so than that
he's figured out a way how to go to
create at a man T improper to smelted
and so what he says is the whole reason
for Wolverine to be brought here is so
that he gain Wolverines healing factor
now at this point
Wolverine cuts his hands using his own
makeshift claws and reveals to dr.
Cornelius that he doesn't have a healing
factor anymore and so for dr. Cornelius
this is a large setback this
a massive setback and so what he does is
tell a person a major Sharpe to kill
wolf rain now major Sharpe is basically
the first step in this experiment in
conditioning that dr. Cornelius has laid
out my dear Sharpe does not have any
adamantium he of course doesn't have any
claws and he doesn't have a healing
factor but he is a prodigious fighter
and he has been conditioned in such a
way that he will only follow the
instructions of dr. Cornelius and so as
both a Wolverine and a major sharp are
fighting one another
Wolverine appears to give up he appears
to simply quit and he tells major Sharpe
to end the conflict to basically kill
Wolverine but this turns out to be a
ruse and when major Sharpe goes to punch
Wolverine will rein dodges out of the
way and breaks the glass which allows
for a Wolverine to actually enter where
dr. Cornelius is at and so Wolverine
immediately incapacitates major sharp
takes his mask off his face and tells
dr. Cornelius to shut down the machines
that are getting ready to pump
adamantium into the bodies of these test
subjects but dr. Cornelius says no dr.
Cornelius says that he's not going to do
this and instead he starts the machines
he activates the machines in order to
begin the adamantium process now why it
was he had done this is really more
speculation than anything but we can go
as far as to say that uh most likely
this was done to simply buy himself time
and is successful in this sense because
what Wolverine does is realizing that he
has to make the choice between saving
these three test subjects or going after
dr. Cornelius chooses to save the test
subjects and so what he does against the
I guess the the advice of Reed Richards
is he pops his claws and when he does he
uses his adamantium claws to destroy the
VAT holding the adamantium inside and so
what happens here is Wolverine is
completely and totally covered in
adamantium and so he uses the I guess a
couple syringes or three syringes of
regenerative serum on the three test
subjects to allow them to cut to recover
from the incisions that have been made
in their bodies where dr. Cornelius
intended to implant the adamantium
inside of them and so once these
individuals are safe Wolverine who is
currently covered in adamantium goes and
I guess continues to pursue dr.
Cornelius from here we switch to dr.
Abraham
yes as he's trying to get away now he
has a helicopter on the roof with a
pilot ready to take off but the problem
here is a pilot helps dr. Cornelius that
he's injured and dr. Cornelius looks
down to realize there's a piece of a
glass in his stomach and his intestines
which of course means that that he may
very well be fatally injured here and so
as Wolverine realizes what's going on as
he comes up behind dr. Cornelius the
pyro the the pilot begins to panic a
little bit now initially the pilot acts
as though he's perhaps going to attack
Wolverine maybe he's going to kill him
but then he thinks better of it and
simply abandons dr. Cornelius and so dr.
Cornelius begins to plead with Wolverine
begins to tell Wolverine that he was
trying to do something great he was
trying to make something great and that
Wolverines had never really done
anything like that before and so what
happens is that presumably Wolverine
kills dr. Cornelius now from this point
Wolverine simply accepts his fate he
accepts the fact that he is going to die
because his body is now covered in
adamantium and while this story comes to
a conclusion with Wolverine simply
sitting in a sunset or sitting in the I
guess in the in the Sun watching what's
going on and effectively dying this does
not present a scenario whereby Wolverine
is simply stabbed through the stomach
and killed what this story does is
effectively give Marvel an out it gives
them a way to bring Wolverine back in
the sense that Wolverine is simply just
covered in adamantium and for some
reason throughout this conflict or
something were to take place whereby his
healing factor became suddenly
unsuppressed whereas healing factor was
reactivated then his healing factor
would keep him alive it would keep him
from dying nonetheless this simply just
brings in a brings an end to the death
of Wolverine story this gives us a
conclusion of what is it taking place
that led up to Wolverine moving away or
being taken out of the of the Marvel
Comics with that being said we're going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates for Marvel explained and
talk to me directly
a few short years gone by
for away I
jeez